population in accordance with communique
that didn't use the word ceasefire
syrian state media had already announced
a conditional truce demanding the
withdrawal of weaponry from a buffer
zone unit lib the syrian government
blamed the turkish for not fulfilling
their role in the sochi agreement last
year had a momentum this has not
materialized on the contrary the number
of terrorists in and lib has increased
namely foreign fighter terrorists in the
opposition despite reservations agreed
to a truce but accused the regime of
violating the sochi agreement taking
advantage of a withdrawal of fighters so
they could launch what it called their
cunning criminal attacks and their
spokesman gave this warm right now there
is no trust and there will be no trust
in the near future when it comes
withdrawing the heavy weapons no heavy
weapons will be withdrawn unless there
are written guarantees but russia says
the biggest fighting group it brands as
terrorists higher tahrir al sham HTS
must be eliminated
turkey has an obligation according to
swatching memorandum to do it if they
cannot do it alone we can render them
some help from us that's why we talked
also today with the opposition about
that if they are interested and if they
need some help also from the russian
federation to fight here today russia
and other radicals and in a depth sown
then they can count on us so we can we
can do it
no one could measure the depth of
distrust between the warring sides after
more than eight years of war hundreds of
thousands dead more than ten million
people displaced
then there's the differences between the
guarantors of these talks iran and
russia on one side turkey on the other
each with their differing interests
nevertheless for so many traumatized
civilians there's hope of some respite
from the bombing but no one needs
reminding that deals done by leaders in
high places
have let the people of Syria down so
many times
Andrew Simmons al-jazeera Nursultan
Kazakhstan